I'm gonna say that one more time because
that that cheer should be a little bit
louder Kobe Bryant the NBA all-star game
kept Kobe Bryant's legacy alive Sunday
night featuring multiple tributes to the
Lakers icon he's going 81 points in one
game scoring 60 points in his last game
he was also passionate about being a
great father husband
Magic Johnson opened the ceremony with
heartfelt words about the late NBA star
the crowd chanted Kobe's name several
times during the speech
there you go
Jennifer Hudson provided the night's
first concert performance honoring Kobe
she's saying an emotional rendition of
the song for all we know with touching
photos of Kobe and daughter Gianna
accompanying the performance common took
a moment to honor Kobe by shouting out
his inspirational impact for basketball
fans everywhere okay Kobe Bryant who
wore purple and gold so even in the
darkest times you'll feel Kobe's life
the all-star players also paid tribute
with their game jerseys with team LeBron
wearing jerseys with the number 24
Kobe's jersey number during its final
years in the NBA and team Jionni's
sporting the number two in honor of
Gianna's jersey number at mamba Academy
[Music]
chance the rapper of little Wayne cave
oh and DJ Khaled all gave powerful
performances at halftime with the final
moments featuring several clips of Kobe
and Gianna
[Music]
et spoke with the all-star players about
Kobe's impact on the NBA all eyes on the
NBA have definitely been on you all the
last few weeks it feels to me like maybe
your team has even galvanized more since
Kobe's death was that something you all
sat and talked about like let's do this
for him I think everyone in the locker
room knows it everyone in the
organization is something that doesn't
need to be talked about no I think we
all came together and you know sharing
some of our best moments but we know we
know that you know we're gonna do he
would be proud of us and we're gonna do
as much as we can to make him proud you
know on the floor and off the floor as
well everything he stood for everything
he embodied we want to continue that
legacy with the Laker organization are
you healing as a basketball family as a
Laker family it's tough I mean there's
there's nothing that you know can kind
of get over right away you know
especially in the Laker organization
he's touched so many people in our
organization that it's something it's
not something that you just get over
with get it over with
no we we we see his numbers every day on
the floor and the facility we wait on
our charities and so it's something that
we we don't get away from and we don't
want to get away from me we try to you
know you know do that as motivation and
firepower and go out and play for him
every night I loved watching his game I
came up on LeBron and just seeing Kobe
and him go at it all the time was just
one of those like the most amazing
things I've seen so just to see the love
of his family I just had a daughter and
I just I couldn't imagine and it was
very heartbreaking he's a legend and you
know legends don't doubt
[Music]